[Applause]
i think i don't been through i ain't
gonna lie
it's like i'm growing this man i ain't
even go like like [ __ ] i've been through
ain't no like not not a normal teenager
i went through that i don't know
already knowing a whole lot what at what
age did you start to get mixed up in
some of the more street [ __ ] because
obviously
you know a lot of your subject content
is very very aggressive and
and is you know was in that world so at
what age did was that
the a side of the world that you were
exposed to and and started to
participate in on any level
like i was always bad as hell like i
remember when i was little like
my next door neighbor this was when i
was probably
i was like six to seven and um he wasn't
even the blood for real
right but he had a red flag he i guess
his big brother gave it to him or
something he had a red flag
i was about six to seven he like three
years older than me
and uh he just walk outside we used to
walk outside with a player there
right then one day he just had me [ __ ]
up like he just walked outside and then
i don't know he who's like he had the
flag he was like i'm a blood and he said
you're gonna be a blood with me too and
i was like
and like oh no that day i was like it
wasn't the fact that
i didn't want to be a blood it was more
so the fact i wanted to be my own man
like i didn't want to go under his wing
to like you know type [ __ ] and i said
well i said if you were blood i said i'm
a [ __ ]
yeah you know what i told him and then
since that day we had started beefing
like i used to always fight with my
neighbor and [ __ ]
and uh like a whole lot of fights in the
neighborhood we ended up moving we had
to move and [ __ ]
i was just bad as hell mom was like man
i ain't gonna lie i already know what
you gonna do out here so we move
but i ain't gonna lie when i move i
really got even more into gang [ __ ]
cause i was more distant from like
the [ __ ] i was growing up with so [ __ ]
it was like i was wanting to do this
[ __ ] more because i went
you had to find new friends yeah yeah
and i ain't want to do this so
really really when i really started
doing it was probably
14 like 13. and the thing is too is like
i've met both your parents and they're
great people and like i feel like you
have a great support system yeah it was
perfect it's just great
support just like you have a great
support system i think it's dope that
you keep your parents close to you
because a lot of people
don't do that and they you know they
they become someone who they're not with
this rap [ __ ] and this hollywood [ __ ]
so like from from you getting into
trouble like that when you were like 14
and [ __ ] like
to you rapping like when did you start
taking this rap [ __ ] serious like dude
no i was like
15 because what what was it what was the
moment though where you were like oh
[ __ ] this
okay like i dropped this song i recorded
this song i was
i think it was when i was 14. i recorded
this song called no love
anthony before i blew up he had 100k on
the audio
like nadio mac it was my first son nah
like on youtube okay that's what was
crazy i got 100k on the audio video
right youtube
and then i was like man this [ __ ] crazy
and it was my first song i ever made my
first song i ever dropped
and so when i did did it at that age i
was like man i ain't gonna do number get
better i started dropping some more
dropping some more
turn 15 i dropped no coolest part three
whole time
i'm i'm i'm i'm i'm flunking in school
i'm
getting back up i'm [ __ ] up i'm
telling but but i'm telling mama i'm
telling my mom
i'm bro it was crazy man every night i
was doing she in her eyes it was like i
was doing
wrong but i was really making my making
my own lane i was making something
i knew what i was going i knew i was on
the right path because like i said i was
saying angel numbers like four foot four
that's teddy on me
and i was like mom on the right path i'm
on the right i'm i got you
and i was like and there was one thing i
said i saw i see a lot how a lot of
[ __ ] treat them as a treat they
positive [ __ ] like i
i treat i got an attitude i treat them a
certain way but at the same time
a real top shouter know that like you
gotta make sure they straight at the end
of the day and the purpose is when you
blow you gotta make sure they go you
they gotta be with you because if your
family ain't with you you're getting fed
to some wolves you wanna you know who
you wanna know who do you think everyone
has [ __ ] up
uh interior motors they got [ __ ] up
deals arterial motors
they trust the knees that's what i was
saying when we i'm like yo when you when
you when you when you went that united
masters route off the rip i'm like this
kid is different
because we know i mean everybody jumps
on that first advance they get offered
yeah for sure and then they [ __ ] it off
and then they got to pay it back and
it's crazy that was offering me three
meal and [ __ ] i went
through united masters i took 150 000
just to play say
you probably got that three men within a
few months
and you own the record shout out to
steve stout man